this is not a beautiful lovely
presentation because I'm a busy woman
and this is an academic paper all right
this will be a pitcher here's the way
this is going to go there's a lot of
text on my slides you can distract
yourself and read the text and that's
fine you can listen to me talk to mine I
love them questions during the talk if
you don't want to be questioned drunk
talk as I finish hopefully have time at
the end and I chose this for those of
you who do not know who I am
beyond runway I happen to be one of the
people that works on the attack Kisuke
project not that much lately but
certainly had time soon didn't get
worked with that project of running it
introductions in large-scale so this
paper is near and dear to my heart I
read it long after I started working
with imagine zookeeper and it's it is
nearly to my heart not because it is
this brilliant theory paper where this
person proves an amazing hero about
begginers would pull up now a foot world
could change it's not that paper right
it's very much an engineer's engineers
paper right
it is about engineering is about what
happens when you take some steps from
papers creates production systems around
them and run them in the face of
terrible brokers
what is chef Jenny the lobsters that was
going to synchronize activities agree
about basic information around their
environment all right design health bill
Brazil with poor screen synchronization
in particular leader election most of
you many may be at least fifteen from
this audience I'm going to guess not
right in production code in the like
early two-thousands in the early 2000s
we didn't have any distributed systems
we had a lot of computers okay we wanted
to do things where we wouldn't have to
like you know go into a box and you know
fail something ourselves fail and I have
multiple servers running but not
actually you know know which one was
able to handle traffic we could have
multiple servers handling traffic right
we had this problem leaders even in just
like basic production system where you
could never do that anymore you just
have to distribute a database cluster
right behind stuff so it was a big deal
to be able to elect a leader this is a
big pressing problem to all engineers
back when this was written back for this
so they identify this need at Google
which is that writing on these
distributed systems we need to
coordinate them in some fashion we need
to provide riveted locks and we need to
let people elect leaders as we have all
these systems that we know they need
leaders from each other okay how does it
work very simple well it used taxes and
we are not going to talk about taxes
don't ask a question about pesos I am
NOT of exos experts there may be some
people here who are and maybe they'll
talk to half of the top but I not have
so such to it hmm I don't want to want
him talking about so but it is sold and
distributed census using an ASA
communication
method and uses access to ensure that
that is a safe process cool all right
and interesting now let's do two deep
fundamental algorithms that they
discovered in this process but
interesting because it talks very
clearly very well and very eloquently
about how to take fundamental algorithm
actually turn them into useful
production systems for hundreds
thousands of engineers thousands of
different kinds of services right ok so
now I'm going to skip the section where
they talk about design we're going to
talk directly about a system structure
first this is just going to be very kind
of rapid-fire talking about the system
structure because I don't think that's
the most interesting part this is a
truck sure all right
you have this group of servers called a
chubby cell a zookeeper those of you how
many of you are familiar with zookeeper
and run it and lots of you have run
zookeeper great so I will probably
translate these things back and forth
into new keepers is equal to one ok
chubby has a master in relevance and the
difference one big difference between
chubby and zookeeper said only the
master serves traffic all traffic reads
and writes go through this master
replicas all right
sell small set servers for whatever
reason they supposed to use five those
of you unfamiliar or have it like you
know seeing you talk about zookeeper for
example in the past you always haven't
had an odd number of these relatives you
have to they don't get any benefit by
having and none on them is you have to
have a majority surviving to be able to
continue to function to be able to
continue to vote and have a majority
there
that's right if you got five you have to
have three available you can lose juice
or systems or get six you still have to
have you have to have that for all right
say it's only lose two serves so our
numbers up master names always writes
great data model is a file based data
model is kind of nice it's very like you
know tangible concepts to engineers it
sports the file system interface some
things sort of directly use this
interface you have LS top path and it is
a box or the food and this is the game
chubby cell they can use that touch a
resolve DNS and point you to the right
cell basically enough and then you've
got your own interpretive basements
right a zoo keywords another small
difference with zookeeper zookeeper
doesn't have anything in its namesakes
by default it tells you which forum you
have to be a part you put that in it's
not you know directly is a namespace in
itself okay only house the direct
lineage our trees are in the namespace
we collectively call these nodes each
node has only one name there are no
links or soft links to harness those may
be persistent permits or penalties Iowa
home said that's a zookeeper terminology
different Kisuke were huge things
different here directories can't contain
data zookeeper directories can contain
it any lope you can take it and have
children zookeeper yes chubbie no
chubbies very much if you're a directory
where your file you're not though if
ephemeral is different in this as well
as federal for those of you familiar
with zookeeper will be deleted when the
client that holds that it created
general node goes away they are very
much session based in chubby ephemeral
nodes are not specialists they are
deleted if no client has been open but
that doesn't you know but any client can
have it right so you can have multiple
clients that have open handles to this
ephemeral file and it won't go away
until they all closed captions
there's also happens as he mentions it
would go to jail they didn't have apples
so very rather they more miscellanea
remove metadata instance number
generation number of operation numbers
equal generation number these are all
useful for bookkeeping making sure that
you are up to date with the latest
version of whatever's on the server I
don't really want to go into that
handles is just a term that refers to
what you might get when you open a node
all right there's sequence numbers that
tell you and a whole bunch of stuff
about this useful for booking a we don't
really care about that we're not going
to judge ourselves if you are okay let's
talk about actually quick because I
think this is one of the parts of the
paper where you may just breeze through
it be like it's cool but let's dive in a
little bit here because it's not obvious
and I know it's all obviously much like
an hour with ITA over there arguing
about the meaning of these laws what
exactly he meant it like that
instead we said culture so first this I
thought the problem was distributed like
the problem distributed locking is the
following survey it's a lock Center
busts dies server B then requires the
same lock and anytime the thing that we
were sending those requests to gets
requests that were serviced by a server
a right now it's server B starts sending
traffic to that resource and that
resource doesn't really have any idea
who's supposed to be talking to it it's
just gonna like respond whatever right
so you know even he's talking to B and
then C or requests from hanging and a
lot of custom and sent it back and you
just have this like totally like
unordered sequence of events that you
don't expect to happen so you don't
expect the resource under lock PI server
B is going to be responding to requests
from server a after it's starting to
talk to the server but it might if you
don't have proper distributed locking so
chubby setup to help solve this problem
and it solved it they talk about these
two ways right okay they talk about the
mathematical way which is like oh you
got much hold less code nobody's
checking in and that's fine and so
here's what we're going to do you're not
to change your resources to check for
locks at all the resources are as
resources have been but we're going to
live this long time so if a loses it
lock because it like dies and it still
has requests in flight B can't get the
log and immediately start sending
requests so that resource may still
responses and requests from a after a
has died but it will not hopefully
hopefully it won't actually send those
or bus back after B has started query
okay just sort of giving it time to
drain out the queue of requests that
will build up by egg layer okay
then they own this thing about seems
okay
sequencer great your sequencer what is
that a lot colder gonna bus the
sequencer super cool it has its
sequencers requests these are servers
and then the other servers are just sort
of validate that sequence information
and also I found a mutant here I've out
of this statement to be confusing the
validity of a sequencer can be checked
in his service Chevy cache or if the
server does not wish to maintain
possession the Chevy the most recent
scenes are that the server has observed
okay Jamie is a Cody Asche no problem
you're familiar with zookeeper you can
in your mind imagine his works like oh
I'm the resource and I'm just going to
like keep an eye on this node
Anna gave a lot and when that note
changes
she'll be sends me and updates and I
know okay great I know it's changed so
hyper make your response request for a
after that's change I just for joke but
this is saying that I can safely
just check the sequence number I don't
have to have a reference to chubby on my
resource and this would still eat out
okay to answer this question I believe I
answer to my own mental satisfaction
that I could be wrong you have to
remember that they say very clearly up
front in the logging section be the loss
our advisory all they guarantee is that
lock loss conflict only the other test
to acquire the same a lot that doesn't
they do not need lock objects
clients not wanna know okay so here's
what I was concerned with right ace
sending requests on a valid sequencer to
resource a de luces the lock be inquires
for any time more requests all these old
request okay are still being processed
by the resource right it has lost the
log but the resource is still processing
them and it doesn't see anything wrong
with that because it has not received
another sequencer that would indicates
anything is missed that would be wrong
if we were talking about mandatory walks
the advisory locks only mean that you
care about it the minute that you can
observe a conflict so we only observe a
conflict once a request from B hits that
resource tones are presently the seven
resource they say oh this is a new
sequence I'm in a new state and the
sequence is valid it's a new to
forward-looking sequence somebody new
must have my loss and now in a process
only that listen to us
I'm going to reject any requests from
the old sequence yes that's a good
question I don't know the answer I'm
sure I will guess depends alignment but
that ensures essentially that you are
never going to see a request from be on
a new sequence and then see an old
request from a and still service that
request but you also don't have to talk
to chubby on you sure on these were
resource side to be able to save videos
well oh it's like the only inside it on
it all right moving on event when you
create a handling because they're not
human subscribe show that ants are
awesome if you're familiar with
you guys are like really important you
can please hold 1,000 modify a child
those are changed with an app that comes
over the handle is invalid they bought
these other ones that I can go to put in
here it always is delivered after the
corresponding actions taken place now
these events are really important
because chubbie is a system Tony online
zookeeper has a very thick clients the
client and chubby does a lot of stuff
because they observe various very early
on in the process of creating a system
that traffic is really kind of expensive
in chubby land and so we wanted to
create clients that could really handle
you know that we can have one clients
out there it's nice to be just standing
so traffic so we have this sort of stick
client to the client an actual
developers don't have to implement
themselves they are implemented by the
chubby team and bestowed upon them via
the thought SOS people plugins all okay
right so so moving on to events where
quickly it's also ties together you'll
bear with me clients cache the file data
and most metadata lay this in memory
write through cache so again if you're
familiar with zookeeper this does not
happen you have to implement this pretty
much yourself right I know has changed
anywhere in this system we don't just
like change it in the master and then
say we're changed do the modification
that node is blocked until all of the
caches
invalidate and if knowledge they have
invalidated that node then we modify
then what happens is that the updates
only invalidate on a client side so the
clients invalidates their node sends a
request that updates to later
right master says everybody else have a
validate we're all invalidated okay
now either the kind group requested that
right is invalid that the client has to
now because another review of that file
to refresh that day so this means that
you're not like preemptively pushing
these rights down to all time so sort of
assumption is like you may not really
need to know the latest state all the
time you do not actually need to notify
you all the time
Lee's going to make sure you're not
cashing anything to stay they are way
more obsessed with you not reading stale
data chubby PRN zookeeper okay chubby
probably for good reasons is a very very
obsessive you not reading sailed it this
is why you cannot connect to anything
but the master as you can only
guaranteed in these protocols that
you're connected to a no that's not the
master that when you do a read will read
the latest value you can always get
behind the zookeeper we still like you
if you haven't found a time in which of
your connection or number is lagging you
might be able behind and provide some
commands they'll force flushes so that
you will get the late state if you
really care one of those you somebody
here knowledge okay so we want to force
everybody to invalidate you always like
really strict notions in our mind about
what correctness is I mean my gross I
care very very much about darkness very
much so I want to make sure that you my
dear clients do not cache a thing and
you don't invalidate you just hold on to
it you keep it keep it tapes and you've
got in Talladega is that driving crazy
driving so crazy
you could be breathing still take a no
no it's the worst thing ever so we have
to keep these sessions alive too chubby
right stateful staple stuff right most
of the things you're doing here on these
clinics are servin a staple okay so we
create sessions relationships we cottage
chubby chubby client
so 1998 lives they are created on first
contact from the light mature master and
they end when they are terminated or
when they're left idle with no open
handles and no no call to action going
on again now there are slight difference
from zookeeper zookeeper as long as your
thing is open and sending her face will
be alive we will just grab to propose
you he Willis are not quite for a circus
or act like cartesianism stargates but
they do some interesting things there's
special RPC that is a lot at the other
master until such time as they clients
timeout the flight stepping out is
almost up
then they respond back and say now you
can increase your timeout these a little
bit longer okay now the nice thing about
these is they'll handle on the same
thread students at the end of the same
thread handle all other events including
cache invalidation including other kinds
of notifications that you absolutely
must act against if you are to stay in
valid state in your client with respect
to Chuck so this is actually very
similar to the ways of keeper and that
thread works if you ever have to reason
through the zookeeper oh that thread
don't kind of mind-bending because you
can be getting lots of different kinds
of events or parking structure going
through this bread right and if
something goes wrong you could be just
chance or thrown off into the river
right these are there there's also all
of this handling of what happens when
you do just going so let's talk about
that really quick and I lock eyes from I
like weak ass eyes but try just
forwarding
how many of you actually went to
graduate school yeah like does it look
pretty good my other Esther's I was like
I think you at least that well okay so
just hold the straight straight up
straight up yeah
Asia okay so what's happening here
basically you don't mind and your master
dies for whatever reason and a new
master must be elected and in the
meantime you do not want your clients to
all have to disconnect not just isn't it
but lose their sessions because sessions
are really big sentence reviews for big
things if you lose your session whole
bunch of stuff is lost you may fail over
like a big table master thing and that
would be really expensive so we all want
to do that so instead what happens is
you can go to this jeopardy period
whereby your event threads can call the
event thread gets the message that is
disconnected for the master and just
continues to try to reconnect in Greek
the ninth reconnect American and finally
what it does it just restarts itself
essentially right basically we don't
want to expire all our price to master
fell over because reach out to sessions
of the night namely ask okay so the
client can doing you work during this
jeopardy table over period but it
doesn't close especially they lose all
the work that has already done all the
stuff that is set up for itself
all right this is an important part of
the design around you know we're
supporting these course great locks or
supporting things that are kind of
expensive and that means we don't want
to lose them if at all how many of you
tweeted this like everybody on my girl
list uh you know we are surprised to
learn of the Taylor goes exercise far
less often in the other part system it's
a rich source of interesting bugs indeed
I can't tell you what they are good
season I'm going to talk about them but
you are welcome to troll through the
history of these year deeper Memphis for
some potential
examples there are many of them alright
this is the shogi system structure
fairly not super straightforward but
straightforward right hitless dead
C++ it server 7oz linesman client so
that's you know it's not tiny that's not
huge alright let's talk about the design
rationale the reason that I love this
paper is not as I find the details of
the way that they implemented chugging
they're slightly different than the
details of the way that Sookie door was
implemented I don't that's kind of
interesting i don't know i'm not i'm not
like a that kind of person I'm
interested in how things fail and how
engineers really work and how you make
so there were two key design decisions
made when they conceived of starting to
build on the first is that they were
building a blog service service is more
important than long as a mo school
library or just a simple service to
create consensus second is serve small
ones so you can actually use the service
not only to get lost to share data
so just advertisement configuration
information why don't the pesos so why
don't you give us with a so the heart
attacks of librarian would depend on no
other services I'll be great and would
provide a standard for programmers
assuming their services in the
implemented as state machines
oh that's just assuming that you did
with those services of save sheets
that's just amazing okay I'm actually
surprised at a library classroom that is
like crazy that's like as it was
understated piece of British wickedness
okay because he'll is other programmers
all right so there are making advantages
doing a service instead of just unlit
passes like number one developer don't
plan for
that's good man I'm just trying to like
get my little experiment on the door my
managers really write me aren't tonight
okay they don't plan for it and if you
want to use a consensus protocol you
have a state machine in there and the
code has to be special structure which
is actually pretty freakin hard a
non-trivial activity and services can
enable you to have code and it's correct
distributed login well I rewrite the
full service you realize this is the
thing that you need how that's really
useful
I'm building a thing to run in a company
with thousands of developers I really
don't want every small ability to have
to re-implement their code they realize
it a nice trip good locking and the only
way to do it implement with that that's
really tolerant am really good we're
talking ideas here Service manages to
alright when you are electing a primary
or petitioning data dynamically you
always gonna tell people what the result
of that was that's just kind of like
sort of obvious in hindsight thing right
so supporting these for division of
small files is really useful and DNS is
a pain in the ass way to do it you can
do it with DNS can adjust
or serving small amounts of data but NS
TTL will kick you very hard in the tooth
and it is number three programmers think
that they understand law cases and Arion
actually understand you guys are clearly
if I should believe that they do some of
them at least find it familiar and
comforting and so at least they will
have like one less bit cool they're lost
one still be wrong but at least the
locks themselves will be correct those
stale locks in this in this house
finally are for distributed that's
algorithms use forums to make videos do
they have to have reference which is by
a default their effectiveness or H a way
that's really nice and especially hazard
a lot of interesting cat you know
implications or basis is not forcing
your client to be perfectly all
available when it needs to make safe
decisions like this can be very useful
it's nice to be able to let your clients
continue to run even they don't have
majority and figure out how to take your
giant pool of machines and create a
subform that to the user and senses also
I suspect is a very nasty and difficult
problem to solve and you probably would
not really want to solve it unless
you're trying to sell the dik-diks okay
take a breath right after all of that
the other point is almost almost seems
like this is like not the big deal which
is oh by the way we're supporting course
prank mommy we're not for my grandma
we're not supporting doing to take a
lock every millisecond you get in a
dragon room I get in her way
now layers of my core frame on which
means that there these locks are very
weakly related at all to the transaction
rate their application they require
waited rarely and they have you can
build system supports much lower load
all right or straight loss how to
protect things that require very costly
recovery computers and again and the
early to thousands of probably still to
this day like it's really easy to reason
about an Astra based system and so you
couldn't want right line it's really
nice to have a system that lets you
reason about a remastered a system and
right now and course my mom experts are
really right this also needs though if
you said this is a model you're
supporting you need to create something
this to survive system failure because
if you lose your locks when your system
your consensus system fails and it may
time to time you're going to cause a lot
of pain on your clients
they're ever going to use you if every
time you have a take a look there's a
networking up to eat them and you all
the sudden they have no blocks they have
no faster and they're you know starting
to our recovery process do I can walk
even without yourself using chubby and
sometimes I'm sure it works but I don't
really not all right little learnings
job but then what
all right how many people use it
answered a zipper named Megan is Deanna
sauce all right most of the time it was
in session people up there were a few
reasons there were very few rights that
was the way that the people that use
this service they observed them in real
time as they were using it that's the
way they and futile outages network
always fails about tears terrible and at
Google it's a Tom but so terrible and
you know Cajun databases will screw that
biggest operator error
they actually very both of a few
failures to report at the time of a
program they learned to do performance
sensitivity of people using chubby which
is that clients really care about late
to chubbies they're not really doing
very much with chubby right there like
right one thing and they leave it for a
really really long time
that's about it did you know it's the
myths were they like really colors that
add random like latency to the clients
until they notice it ratcheted up
ratcheted up they just didn't know we
noticed it's all like like they had like
you know really like hit them very hard
another nobody noticed there's nobody
here I know we cared about the lady to
Chuck but they were really really
sensitive to the late seek on their
actual local cache again this was a it's
you know intelligent design decisions
that they that the creators made to free
these were really thick passes they knew
that like you learn more beautiful lot
and we make them do the round Network
nachos gonna be a real hit yet we create
is very accurately you know whatever
local caches that they just you know
spin those regions much they want the
server would overload about you know
nine thousand sessions or my stand a lot
and the scalability ended up reducing
deviation squeeze relationship but a
proxy in front of us all of these
problems they just a little proxies
proxy proxy proxy for
say John emanuelly who writes Chuck come
on Hughes at my doorstep Google 2004 oh
jeez it's not quite Roxy but I I was
sort of politics basically Oh needs or
if somebody's using us for a game
service they don't really need it to be
like a chubby level crazy accurate so we
can create also a little proxy thing for
our nature right which is a trusted
process which is prop Castle requests
from other clients through which IV sell
it just provides that aggregation point
so that you know you've got fewer people
lives so it's chuck itself looking less
happy in will in the proxy she's up soon
as proxies probably had almost much
complexity and some of their code is
should be salted that doesn't have to
have the voting on all that so ladies no
direction proxies usual but she will
want answers why it was you want to in
service for CNS is a pain in the ass to
scale and I think they did a really nice
job explaining this right you have three
thousand servers they would communicate
with each other together sixty second
time to live that is 150 thousand of us
per second that is a lot okay this is
for three thousand servers with a pretty
long time school so this is clear TNS
scale forever
DNS is great maybe it's got more now on
business is another change right the
change of what would be as reliable so
you should be grateful
uh you know Shelley can handle more
clients than a single VMs can but not
enough more but also they just don't
need to talk to show you as much because
you know okay so watch out okay
do we mention the problem with other
programmers and how they are difficult
it will rate group loose that will
possibly retried help hands
it sure will it will try to use this as
a datastore service it sure well
oh right like a lot of data Anna
they lock service for good pasta
messaging system yeah really doesn't
smell don't do that
okay they rarely sir availability they
don't think about the other
probabilities really understand circuit
systems it blindly will follow your API
but also kind of not really view to
documentation they are a terrible looks
and they basically go print the future
very well and that goes for Mike himself
as he admits in this paper he really did
not heard it exactly the way the system
of these fortunately he's a brilliant
person and so so how do you mitigate the
impact of developers if you have ever
had to support a large centralized
production zookeeper service you're
familiar with probably all of these
things which is you can review all their
own review whether they want to use the
system then you entirely control the
clients and then you just insert random
lifetime [ __ ] timeouts in the client so
that if you do something bad it's going
to be really painful to you and finally
a throw up your hands and say okay I
can't yogi hey guys I'm going to recive
Lee ash even more than I thought it was
going to press the cache when I original
Sciences in conclusion centralized
services are useful for many reasons
creating shared or architecture is
really hard and it is really impressive
how well this system did and is held up
to time developers and will screw you
always always hell with other developers
never prevent having fundamental
insights and empathy with your customer
which is in this case other developers
at your company helps you make actually
really good decisions right helps you
think about like no really what is the
problem that I am trying to solve they
were I think that one of the best things
that Mike did with his paper and hope
I'm going to assume that he did it in
real life - I don't know is heaving it
really really clear what this system was
for and what
was not for and by having that clarity
it's very easy to communicate not fine
green logging know at a developer not
migrate logging or strain locking only
I'm going to review your code until you
understand forcefully and locking
rolling but that net that he did
something very awful very specific very
well tuned for exactly the use cases
that needed to serve and those cases
were really really important and this is
the lessening of you all segue if you
don't understand that any of the rest of
us thoughtfulness empathy with your
client is useful even air and
infrastructural that advance
I thank you and we'll open questions
would you say fair say that Netflix
narrator library makes zookeeper more
similar to chubby Sark experience
narrator curator people want oh yeah
yeah so that's what the question is
curator from Netflix which is a client
that grass is fro janeiro zoo keeper
client make zookeeper similar to chubby
and the answer is maybe I don't know the
details of a curator does that well I
think that probably somewhat yes and
then like one of the challenges of
zookeeper because you gotta use it
implement everything from bass princess
right whereas it's very clear that like
chubby implemented some of those
primitives or right and carried or tries
to do that in zookeeper as well and if
you did if you you know I think that
probably in reality yes you should just
use generator and you should give people
thick clients and I think that was maybe
a little bit of an error on the part of
the zookeeper team on the other hand
like some people really want to handle
different kinds of failure at different
recipes connected very differently and
zoo here doesn't have a wife a level of
strictness of sort of freshness of data
that chubby ass I think that is
difficult to overcome that with a thick
clients unless maybe to be if you
develop your way up to do it that's the
nice thing about chubby is earning
Happy's get clients they can cash really
aggressively they can know the Masters
and it's helped it when that thing is is
invalid it's not really like punish you
if you don't clear it out right whereas
mizuki burr like you really do that
correctly you know you better be
connected to a know that is a fair
picture far behind the leader to drip a
little thin on leader it depends on how
accurate your own practiced assumptions
are so it's kind of like more or less
ability as you hear but also more ways
you can screw it up as result yeah so I
work on pub/sub messaging at Google yeah
so you're you're right everything you
said is absolutely will just end right
the people who weekend and I was like
wait why don't I go and like look at our
own usage chubby and like see if we
actually did it correctly and I was I
think I found some holes and way we use
it so even like this kind of simple
interface like what you're saying about
programmer sticking they know how to use
mocks and not knowing how to use locks
like that's even with this interface you
can you can mess it up right like you
have this caching that chumpy manages
for you in life you might naively copy
something out of the cache and then you
now you have two copies of it like the
chubby client library is managing your
cash it's up to date you still have this
you know like out of date hot so like
you know and like what you said about
the chubby team like there's a guy down
the hall who works on the chubby team
who's basically he has white hair and a
beard and every time I see him I just I
feel comfort drive people out in the
industry and a 45 company was koppers
was it again to use in their conference
they look like that before he started
working on champion other questions yes
I was surprised that chummy maintains
these permanent sessions with 19,000
clients
it seems when you have 9,000 clients one
of them is
this be a die every time we deal with
how do they avoid so I don't know the
answer exactly right so the question is
there are so many liens that could be
it's connected to these jobbies cells
and given the likelihood of one of those
clients terribly misbehaving and
affecting everyone else how do they make
sure that that doesn't happen do you
think the bread crumbs in the paper
gives us are the following that they
make it really clear that developers
don't care too much about latency of
stuff so when you write sometimes those
race' quite a while to propagate through
the system is repeat done and it doesn't
seem like a closet up to the point of
this anger they caused them have any
problems I guess the other points they
do say that they have problems when a
single session is like really stabbing
them like this cache is this behaving it
constantly evaluated and them they do
have that probability the way that they
handle it is they review the code they
review systems they punish that
behaviour in their client logic itself
up make these sort of exponential
back-off some things like that into the
client logic so you know I don't know
like that's that's all they were to tell
me is that I don't know if one of our
Googlers wants to China but two quick
things so one one IIM a rule since
internship that second so I think no
idea how it works now but I do know that
they just kill your service if you miss
be like they're people - you're a good
trophy with julia practicum the second
thing is is that because it's mostly
read traffic and because they have the
heartbeats that are like
because they re traveling and because I
have the heartbeats they pretty sure
they use multicast oh yeah yeah they're
not UDL which is like there's lots of
Google networking they may not actually
though of the way that it works is you
know remember all these on the mentoring
background response to the RPC and so
you know if I'd to exists because it has
a pending perk beat but when you said
their response you don't wait for that
response to get Mellish before you know
proceeding so it's okay if you send a
bunch of cash bail and get lost because
that's like looking this manager to the
protocol because you know they're going
to be it's going to be a bit that
clients like tinker's I think it's going
to try to piggyback those abilities on
responses and then there's lots they're
just kind of I'm actually not sure
you're right about that I think my
suspicion is that they expect the hack
of the invalidation to be paying back on
keyboards and if there is no equity
validation of people I they don't icon
for eagle eyes and they're you're not
gonna like Ebola if you look at that
that's my suspicion so it should be
sufficient
a validated site before you do anything
else you're going to yes that I would
that yes you know who you don't know
wait for it but I guess my ex my my
point was that if you don't process
there next people live until they give
you a an ass then they'll then they'll
die so that's what you took I'm not sure
I understood the original question
correctly but just in case none of that
will help you have a client that is just
aggressively just reading too much or
trying to open too many files and just
taking away more than their share of the
cell's resources then what I'm imagining
is to put 90,000 clients and one of
those clients is going to be dead
um dead is okay to keep like within 12
seconds or something the key you'll
realize when they don't act the people
eyes what they're not right and we don't
actually have to block until we know
it's dad exactly so compromise they're
spanning a network yeah and there's
there's you know you get some hints in
the paper about the I guess in
particularly there was a problem with
spamming up open if a client tries to
open a file and it's not there they
think it must just not be there yet and
surely it will be there but begin yeah
and that's where they put in like the
the arbitrary 60 seconds ladies but no
one noticed is a it's designed to be
used on a on a secure network right so
it's not a web service it's like an
engine or it's an internet service so so
it it still has adversaries information
back programs written by
and remembers but again it has much more
influence over them than it would you
know a stand Network from like Russia or
something trying to do whatever ray
tubes open the outside so there's like
many other ways to solve that level and
just sort of an updated cheating answer
not in the paper at all but they are
also just ray tackles on the RPC system
now so you just can't send too many
pieces used to it the underlying system
the course of that is that on that on
our pcs in general or so when they study
the course of study that's right it's
also about that like with such a like
strongly consistent cash you can do all
kinds of things with the cash that you
can grab read locks in the cash like
without talking to the server because it
sound like if someone wants to grab a
write lock then they just sort of like
similar to like invalidation so like
they can really like cut down on the
retry but like yeah if you're if you're
opening every file HIV there's nothing
other questions any one on the back
anyone else
okay super fun apparently a public
Google engineers here because like other
though the house act if you look like
they've got nothing
although that means coming home soon so
it was super hot being here thank you
all so much happy to chat a little more
or I go home